Star wars visions is going to be
an exciting anime anthology series
coming to disney plus in september japanese
animation inspired a lot of the people at
lucasfilm over the years we loved the idea
of seeing star wars expressed in that way
each one of these studios that we approached
we found hardcore star wars fans
they all had a story they wanted
we were looking for something from the
heart and soul of the individual creators
they are their visions to the lens of star wars
there are so many genres at play big and
bold romantic and sweeping funny comedic
we tried to have some retro vintage feeling
we couldn't skip the asteroid
influence people loved us trouble
we feel so fortunate to be working with these
filmmakers there's so many opportunities to
reflect japanese storytelling in a star wars
universe star wars visions is completely
different than everything else in star wars
storytelling audiences will fall in love with it
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
star wars visions trailer for the new disney
plus series that's coming this september 22nd
they're gonna be dropping all the episodes at once
i'll explain what's going on with this because
obviously star wars doing anime officially in an
official capacity is a really big deal they've
been ripping off japanese films and anime films
for a long time so this is them finally just owing
up to that like okay clearly a lot of star wars is
inspired by japanese cinema so this is us just
paying homage to that but if you're brand new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos i will be doing at least one or two videos
for this because they will be dropping the entire
thing all at once won't be like a normal weekly
series that i would do episode videos for like the
mandalorian or some of the other upcoming series
like the book of boba fett which is kind of like
the mandalorian season 2.5 also explain what's
going on with that in the mandalorian season 3
at the end of the video just because it's been
a while since we've talked about star wars series
so if you have no idea why star wars is suddenly
doing anime this is going to be a small anthology
series of short films and they're dropping it all
at once netflix style so i don't know how long
all the short films are going to be i'm guessing
between 5 and 10 minutes long each not that long
they won't be the length of full episodes which
is kind of disappointing i was hoping that they
would do like one episode per different studio
but the way they're explaining it they're just
doing shorts so maybe if the series is successful
enough they will green light a full length star
wars anime series in the future the series will
overlap with the episodes from marvel's what if
series and that's going to be a full-length series
with 10 episodes so a little more traditional what
you would expect from a big disney plus series
but basically this star wars vision series is
taking the place of star wars bad batch episodes
which is their current animated series which
is kind of like a continuation so to speak of
the clone wars the bad batch in general just isn't
quite as popular on youtube right now just because
it's more aimed at children i think the star wars
anime series is a little more adult animation also
because you have the whole idea of subs and dubs
the degree of difficulty in watching anime is just
a little bit higher unless there is a really good
dub but all you long time star wars fans probably
do know about the long history of japanese films
just in general inspiring star wars movies and
the newer stuff like the mandalorian even when
john favreau and dave filoni started making the
mandalorian of course they were inspired by the
classic star wars movies a new hope empire strikes
back return of the jedi but overall the series is
also very much inspired by the lone wolf and cubs
series like mando and grogu and even george lucas
has talked a lot about how the original star wars
and new hope film heavily borrowed from akira
kurosawa's hidden fortress so i actually find
it stranger that star wars waited this long to do
some anime inspired series i think mostly because
disney just in general is kind of afraid of anime
even though disney did distribute the miyazaki
films in the west for a little while and despite
the fact that in this trailer they basically admit
that most of the animators and people working at
disney on all these shows and movies are just as
big a weebs as anyone else i imagine one of the
executives lucasfilm that greenlit this anime
series just caught a couple of the animators
on their male accounts one day like okay please
explain what's going on with all this so then
all the younger people had to explain how anime
was so much better than a lot of western animated
series and if you haven't seen it yet there has
already been star wars anime a couple years ago
there was this fantastic star wars anime fan film
completely animated by a fan called tie fighter it
was amazing in 100 percent proof of concept that
star wars done as anime or just anime star wars of
any kind can be amazing if given the proper care
so all the anime studios that star wars partnered
with for this project are known for very strong
visual styles so just going in order of the list
that they provided of all the different episodes
this might be the official episode order of the
series but episode one is called the duel it's
being done by studio kamikaze duga who's mostly
known for doing the jojo's bizarre adventure
series they also did batman ninja which i think
was kind of popular i wasn't quite as big a fan
of that this is the episode where you see the
dueling samurais one jedi one sith seeming like
they're going to fight each other in a futile
japan looking version of the star wars universe
does this not look very similar to the mandalorian
season 2 episode 5 the ahsoka tano episode which
itself dave filoni said was directly inspired
by yojimbo another akira kurosawa samurai film
you could also find some similarities in this
episode to hayao miyazaki's princess mononoke
episode 2 is called lop and ocho is being done
by geno's studio who's mostly known for doing
the golden kamui series which i haven't actually
had the chance to check out yet but i do know that
it's very strong this one seems like the furry
episode like you'll have to explain to all your
friends when recommending it i'm totally not a
furry but this does look very strong episode 3
is titled tatooine rhapsody it's being done by
studio colorito which is mostly known recently
for doing a whisker away film and burn the witch
i like burned the wish just a little bit more than
a whisker away but both are pretty solid this
seems like it's the one with the crashed x-wing
on tatooine although it's not clear which other
footage belongs to this episode in particular then
studio trigger is doing two different episodes one
is titled the twins and then the other is titled
the elder most of you will know studio trigger
for their very very distinct very strong visual
style even without looking at any list you could
probably tell some of the footage that came from
studio trigger most of you will probably know them
from kill lock hill which is their biggest hit
they also just released the pro mirror film
they're mostly known as a studio that does really
new really weird really cool stuff but tends to
do a lot of one-off series like we're gonna do
one series or one movie that's really awesome and
they just moved to a completely different project
the story about the twins is obviously about the
forced twins one of them going to the dark side
one of them on the light side and them having to
face each other like you can see them going up
against each other as if one of them has become
an inquisitor and one of them becomes a jedi the
episode about the elder is just the jedi master in
the padawan encountering this unknown enemy this
old man sith here with the red lightsaber cannot
wait to see what they did with these episodes of
all the different studios and episodes that star
wars green lit these are probably some of the ones
that i'm most excited about episode 5 is called
the village bride is being done by studio kinema
citrus who's mostly known for doing made in abyss
rising of the shield hero in tokyo magnitude 8.0
maiden abyss is probably one of the best recent
anime series for the last couple of years that
i still have not found the time to watch for some
reason shield hero is also a pretty strong isekai
series if you're looking to get into isekai if
you haven't seen that yet or if you're just a
fan of that genre this seems like it's mostly
inspired by the japanese mountain culture and
is a slice of life anime mixed with some light
side and dark side force elements then there's an
episode called akakiri and tob1 by science saroo
they're mostly known for doing the netflix series
devilman crybaby in japan sinks i'm a huge fan
of devilman crybaby i have not watched japan's
sinks yet but overall i've heard the response
isn't quite as strong as it was to devilman
this seems like it's the episode with the young
kid in the robot they have a very strong visual
style so we'll see then the last episode is just
called the ninth jedi being done by production
ig who's mostly known for doing attack on titan
in the ghost in the shell series everyone on the
planet has seen or at least knows about attack
on titan and ghost in the shell both very strong
even though they each have their ups and downs in
terms of quality throughout their relative series
this seems like it's about the female jedi
character but it's not clear what other footage
is part of this series from this trailer here
what'll probably wind up happening because they're
dropping all these episodes at once is that
i'll do at least one video for everything like
an easter eggs video breakdown video when it gets
a little bit closer and they announce their plans
for how this is all going to work with the release
schedule on disney plus then i'll make some more
concrete plans i'm really excited to see what they
do with it and i do hope that it is successful
enough that they green light a full length anime
series everyone let me know in the comments though
if this anime experiment is successful what do you
want them to do with star wars anime in the future
just in terms of other big star wars disney plus
stuff is happening this year the book of boba
fett episodes will be the only big live-action
star wars stuff coming and that's not supposed
to be released a little bit closer to christmas
time at the end of the year the way the actors
have explained it ming na tamura morrison pedro
pascal is that the book of boba fett is kind of
like the mandalorian season 2.5 i believe it's
going to be about four episodes it could be more
they haven't completely explained that part of it
but they're actually not going to be able to film
the mandalorian season three and they are making
the mandalorian season three till sometime early
next year so it will be a bit of a delay for the
mandalorian season three and the only reason why
that's happening though is because they're using
all the studios they would normally use to film
the mandalorian series for filming the obi-wan
series so if you're upset that mando's season 3
is delayed just blame ewan mcgregor in obi-wan so
we will be getting those episodes obviously before
we get mandalorian season 3 episodes so there
will be live-action star wars stuff happening
next year we also have the rogue one prequel
series as well i've already done a big video
about the book of boba fett for the post-credits
scene for the teaser trailer they released so i'll
put a link for that down in the description
my full loki episode 5 video will post on
wednesday just like normal my full rick and morty
episode 3 video will post monday while you wait
for everything everyone click here for my full
loki episode 4 video and click here for that loki
post credits scene thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!